- Hey, everyone.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
in to another spellbinding,
that's right, spellbinding
edition of Market Takes.
Listen, I know you could have
been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me
and I appreciate that.
I'm your host, Dion Rabouin,
reporter at The Wall Street Journal.
Listen, there is a lot going on right now.
There's a lot to explain and
I think we could be in store
for a big potentially
market moving week of data
in terms of the information
that we're gonna be getting.
It's gonna be coming at us from all sides
but I have the three most important things
to look for this week.
I'm gonna break down what
they are, why they matter
and do a little separation
of the signal and the noise for you.
First off, we have this
week's CPI inflation report.
That is the big one that I think all eyes
in the market will be on
but there are some other very key pieces
of data we'll also get.
Second, we get the NFIB'S
Small Business Optimism Survey.
That is out Tuesday, tomorrow.
You're gonna wanna look at that.
I'll explain why.
And third, Congress returns to Washington,
both the House and the
Senate later this week.
So expect to see a lot of
headlines about the debt ceiling.
I'm gonna explain what
that is, why it matters,
what to really look for in
terms of what we get this week
because there's gonna be a lot
of information flying at you.
I'll break all that down in just a minute.
So let's start with the big one.
First off, this week on Wednesday,
we get CPI, the Consumer Price Index.
We'll be right here on
Market Takes breaking down
what happens with that.
What you're gonna wanna
look for is listen,
inflation is still very high,
still much higher than the
Federal Reserve wants it
and that's shown in the data.
So wanna put something up
here on your screen right now,
just give you an idea of
what we're looking at.
Now, we've seen inflation
consistently coming down
over that time period.
You see it picking up
through 2021 and into 2022.
Then it hits 9% in June and
it's come down every month
since then pretty consistently.
We are now at about 5% though.
That's still more than
double the Fed's target
and still the highest inflation.
If you take out this 2021-2022 period,
still about the highest we
would've seen in 20 years.
So lower, but still not low.
The other key piece,
this is another chart I wanna put up here
on your screen right now,
and that is the core consumer price index.
That's when you take out
volatile food and energy prices.
What you see there, the
index doesn't go up as high,
it doesn't reach that 9% level
but you see it start to pick up.
And last month in March or
last month, we got the report
for March that showed
inflation on the core side,
CPI core inflation rising to 5.6%.
Now, why does that matter?
I know what you're thinking.
Food and energy, that's gas and food,
what I buy at the store, what I eat
that's most of what I spend my money on
and that's true for a lot of folks.
But what the Fed feels
like it can control,
things that are more
interest rate sensitive
are measured here by this CPI core number.
And as you see, that really
has not been coming back down.
And in fact, it actually
increased in March.
And so that tells you
that what the Fed's doing isn't
having the intended effect.
So this chart, these two
charts really just illustrating
the difference that we are seeing
between the overall CPI
and inflation and the core
inflation, what the Fed watches
and what the Fed thinks of as a predictor
or a kind of indicator of
where inflation is headed.
If that's correct, inflation
could be headed back up
and that's why you'll
wanna watch the CPI report
that we get this Wednesday.
Also, last week if you were here
with us on market takes
on Friday, we talked
about the jobs report and we talked
about have that average hourly
earnings number picked back
up last month unexpectedly rose.
And that could mean
that inflation is starting
to pick back up in the US.
We also have seen
around the world inflation
starting to pick back up.
You saw central banks in
Norway and in Australia kind
of surprise markets with a
rate hike as in raising rates
after they thought,
both central banks kind
of thought they were done and
then boom had to say, okay,
well, inflation's picking back up again.
We gotta raise rates.
You could see something like
that from the Fed, maybe June,
maybe further down the line.
You're gonna wanna watch that report.
CPI on Wednesday.
Be with us here on Market
Takes 10:00 AM Eastern time.
Next up, the NFIB Small
Business Optimism Report.
I wanna put up here on your screen a chart
of what we've seen from that
report in recent months.
Now, this report, I wanna
point out a couple things.
You see the downward trajectory, right?
Pretty obviously going down.
We aren't at those all-time low levels
that we hit back in late 2022
but we are heading that way.
The other thing you wanna look for
is you see the highest
number, the highest reading
that we've gotten since the
start of 2022 was 97, right?
Well, if you look back
over the history of the survey,
49 years, almost 50 years,
the average is 98 and we
haven't even had a reading
of 98 since the beginning of 2022.
We are well below that.
And if confidence continues
to move lower, well,
this is historically bad.
Again, you would normally
have about half the readings
above that 98 number, half below.
We have seen nothing
but readings below that 98 number.
You see nothing but down,
down, down and below 98.
That's the 49-year average.
So we are seeing consistently
declining sentiment
among businesses, and
that chart right there
just illustrating that declining sentiment
and how low sentiment has been
for some time among small businesses.
15 straight months below
the 49-year average.
And that's really
important because listen,
small businesses have
done all the net hiring.
Since 2020, since the pandemic,
all the hiring has been
done by small businesses,
and we are starting to see
more small businesses cut jobs,
and actually reduce and
have to lay off workers,
right as they were just starting
to really pick up the pace
and hire more workers.
We're seeing that trend reverse
in some of the JOLTS data that we've seen.
Basically, the engine of growth
for the US economy is starting to stall
and we are seeing that.
Wanna put one more chart up here
on your screen that really kind
of shows us what we've seen
in terms of big companies versus small.
That green line is the QQQ Nasdaq index.
That's the Nasdaq 100 big companies
like Meta, Amazon, Alphabet, Apple,
all those huge tech names
that you hear about.
Those have returned over 20% year to date.
Now, in the middle of that
red line, that's the S&P 500,
that's done about 7% year to date.
But that blue line you see,
that's the Russell 2000.
Those are those small companies,
those companies more tied
to the overall health of the US economy.
That's basically been a 0% return
for investors so far this year.
So this illustrating
really the big difference,
the huge difference between
what big companies are doing,
how investors are putting
their money into big companies,
how they're putting their
money into small companies.
Obviously, investors having a
lot more confidence right now
in the bigger companies,
those big tech names
and that's what we're seeing.
So how could this affect the real economy?
Because those small businesses we know
are the growth engine.
Small businesses are
showing increased layoffs.
The latest JOLTS survey showed 72%
of the increase in
layoffs was from companies
with one to nine workers, 72%, almost 3/4.
The those companies had about
185 increase in layoffs.
That was about 72%.
Firms with over 5,000
workers had a zero increase
from February to March compared
to a significant increase
from those smaller companies.
You are just seeing a big difference
between what's happening
at large companies and small companies
and we're seeing it in
terms of hiring and layoffs.
So this NFIB Small
Business Optimism Survey
will be the first piece of data
that we have seen that
tells us what's happening
with small businesses
since this banking crisis.
And we know small business is more reliant
on banks than big ones.
We also get, as a bonus later today,
we get the Fed Senior Loan
Officer Opinion Survey
that's gonna tell us
whether banks are
tightening lending standards
or loosening them.
We are already at recession
levels on that indicator
and we will see what the
latest numbers tell us.
Moving on to the debt ceiling,
we get the debate can begin this week.
The House is returning today,
the Senate returns tomorrow.
Really quick, let's step back
and talk about what the debt ceiling is.
Debt ceiling is just a cap on
how much the US can borrow.
We technically already reached the ceiling
in January of this year, $31.4 trillion.
We know that this has been
raised pretty consistently.
It's generally, it had been
just sort of a routine measure.
Since 1960, Congress has
increased the debt ceiling 60
or 78 times, excuse me, most recently
in 2021, 49 happening under
Republican presidents,
29 happening under Democratic presidents.
Really what it is is it's
just hey, we gotta pay
for all these other things
that we already paid for,
that we already bought, and
we have to pay for 'em now
by borrowing more money.
The US doesn't make enough money,
anywhere near enough money in taxes
to actually pay for the things
that it spends money on.
So they have to borrow money,
and that's why we've got a national debt
of 31.5 almost trillion dollars
and that's where that comes from.
And so that's gotta be paid,
and Fed chair Jerome
Powell has said, "Listen,
there's no reason we should
even be discussing this matter"
but Congress meets this week
and you're probably gonna
hear a lot about that.
So really quick, let's take a
look at the timeline, right?
April 18th was the most
recent thing that happened.
That was tax day.
That showed how much tax
receipts had come in.
And that's why Fed
or I'm sorry, Treasury
Secretary Janet Yellen had said,
"Listen, we are going to, by June 1st,
run up against the ceiling
where we aren't gonna be able to pay
for certain things."
She hasn't said what those
certain things are going to be,
but the Treasury has looked
at how much money is coming in taxes.
They've looked at how
much money they have,
how much borrowing they can do
and they've said by June
1st, sorry, June 1st,
we are gonna have to stop
paying for some things.
And really, Congress will
have about a week after that
to come up with a deal.
Now, here's why this week
and the week after are
gonna be so important.
The House is out of Washington
the week of May 29th
through June 5th.
The Senate is out from
May 22nd to May 29th.
So if they don't get anything done
before the end of next week,
they're going to be out.
One branch is gonna be
out in the following week.
The next branch will be out,
and at the end of that week,
you're going to already
run into that deadline
that Treasury Secretary Janet Yellen says
we are going to hit.
So this week is going to be big.
Next week will also be big.
You'll hear a lot about that.
The Treasury market is
already showing some worries.
If you look at the T-bill market,
you're seeing some of those
Treasury bills that mature
around the time the
debt ceiling comes due.
Those have been raising in yield,
which means declining in price.
And you're already seeing investors react
to the possibility of maybe not
getting a debt ceiling deal.
This week will be very important.
If it looks like we're not getting a deal,
you could see some Treasury
yields start to spike.
That could move the stock market,
as well as other markets around the globe.
Hey, listen, that's gonna do
it for us here on Market Takes.
Thank you so much for tuning in.
I know you could have
been anywhere in the world
but you were here with
me and I appreciate that.
I'm Dion Rabouin, reporter
at The Wall Street Journal.
We'll be here Wednesday, 4, or I'm sorry,
Wednesday 10 AM Eastern
time to unpack CPI.
Hope you'll be with us when
we do it again next time.